bientôt celui ci aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour une petite compilation de
jeux gratuits ou grosse tout de suite
avec boxes bagels heure de jeu alors ça
se joue en solo j'adorerais qu'il est
multi mais lyon n'a pas tardé game en
gros c'est une sorte de fps cubique
voilà on va l'appeler comme ça donc on
joue contre des bots voilà parce que le
jeu étant une sur deux bêtas finalement
bras voyez il faut tuer les gens par
exemple l'âge et la cour intérieure je
suis patron vous voyez voyons pas
mouillé moynier est-ce que tu bois ou la
wiimote thomas king moynier là il y
avait là courant je vais voler la
couronne je suis le roi rang gérant chez
roge beaubien jeu passera sa pointure
[ __ ] tu moffatt on y est comme ça mais
regardez mes balles elles tirent pas à
mon fait tire pas à mes balles voilà je
suis très douée en kick sco peut-on s'en
donne un euro en quoi non mais attendez
[ __ ] tu vas pas me faut une pile ok tu me
laisses médecine et de manière virile se
plaît le budget à situer le mec à la
couronne pour lui voler la couronne
voilà c'est un petit peu comme le
journal galette des rois pour les
mauvais joueurs on voit de la couronne
non non non non ben voilà qu'on apprend
la couronne mais arrêtons ce tome est
déballé tout deux snipers et toi tu te
retournes études se moque je veux la
courade deux mois la [ __ ] coiffer la
couronne je me suis allé tout robert
ce prime à la fac où elle couronne a dit
se cacher derrière peter hall à brel ou
jacques brel je suis pratiquant l'humour
depuis 2002 abbas est très drôle
lui je vais tellement le tuer quoi bon
dans son agence mais je peut se refuser
à ces fusils à pompe voilà tu non pas sa
couronne au do you lost mais alors il ya
un deuxième mode qui s'appelle le mode
path bouët où elles toutes les trois
secondes la balle va dans les bras de
quelqu'un d'autre
tu fais quoi mais quoi il va céder ses
diégétique ol était bossu la personne
n'a de bâle en fait j'ai l'impression un
peu n'ont jamais une balle au il avait
la boulette il a raté il m'a achevé avec
sa pop de pied comme ça alors non déjà
harmattan marche pas comme ça qu'on fait
ok alors lui il va me mets mais c'est
très humiliant moyer coup de pied comme
ça mais non mais met dedans mais l'asie
chez la belge à balles réelles urfer
genre l'a pas vu à temps
la partie se termine de 30 secondes à je
te donne plus d'infos c'est fini on a
gagné c'est la fin de la guerre
on est maintenant sur ce qui change
cette plateforme assez original vous
allez le voir
alors je crois que le concept en fait
c'est que l'on fait tourner nous mêmes
voilà vous voyez le décor bouge autour
de nous ok c'est pas chiant ce parce que
vous croyez vraiment s'amuser en plus et
le but c'est d'arriver au bout du
parcours et la [ __ ] elle va plutôt
voir attendant mais c'est breguet ou pas
mais c'est pas mal comme idée quand même
regarder en oui oh oui oh un chez nous
et au revoir
j'adorais quand même mais comme est
complètement [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] ça passe ça passe
ah c'est super dur quoi honey honey
honey honey honey honey honey on ignore
niang adam dunn londonien honni on n'y
est pas c'est pas mal ça non mais à
chaque fois je me refais la solidarité
d'automation salaire à toi même tu sais
on est là pour tout l'araignée isi ont
fait baisser le pied tout j'ai lu
descend du plafond dans un calme absolu
quoi elle sait que la fil bell le sait
la conne c'est pas là comme à la mène on
t'a vu on à l'ukraine dans ton jeu on
sait à quoi tu ressens maintenant on a
deux profils étaient empreintes je le
faisais sur une année depuis 20 minutes
mais gallas y avait quoi les nommer je
suis même pas en train de nous mais
[ __ ] même pas en train de vous mais ça
le pire
elle paraît bien ridicule quand u2 ou
moi alors je vous dis un truc hockey
pendant le reste de cette vidéo je ne
serai plus le même je vais avoir des
yeux braqués là tout le temps c'est
parti on joue on s'amuse vraiment à à la
lys
dalé lary d'investir panique de ouf on
l'a fait on l'a fait on l'a fait aulas
fait on fait ça ensemble un allié ou
quoi ou mon 3g soit qui n'est pas
sensible aux cris puisque vu comment je
criais va vraiment vraiment c'est avec
oui la [ __ ] de sortie s'il vous plaît
excusez moi je n'occupe qui tourne la
sortie acquis essentiel doit être sur un
côté genre l'appareil en dessous de tête
ouais ok j'ai vu ok il va
lalalalalalalalala non elle bouge elle
bouge elle bouge elle bouge
elle me regarde elle veut vivre cette
vidéo en live salut de coups de [ __ ]
l'abonné l'achète je n'ai plus accès pas
des dieux à cliquer sur s'abonner merwe
à chaque fois je me fais avoir
vous imaginez pas je fais ça avec ma
bouche les galas rennais qui vient là
comme ça et le coup ça fait je l'espère
vont là logiquement ça l'arrivée par la
voilà voilà voilà voilà
ok il ya un bug maintenant c'est moi qui
fais tourner moi même le début ce bon ça
là c'est passé oh là là mais quel talent
et quelle modestie
meiway la modestie de mes chiens act up
à ouaga ratchet pas quoi à nadal elle a
bougé
ah oui tiens t'es là c'est [ __ ] je
voulais piqué le pied elle voulait
piquer le corps je faisais une vidéo
elle est plus là au juste au milieu des
voitures
l'embarquement pas moi je suis désolé
mais là la balle se situe juste là sous
vos pieds c'est mort je peux plus jouer
à jeu on a envie d'y jouer regarder des
vrais meinau la fille du dénouer la 203
ne soit jamais l'achat soit j'arrête une
bombe anti araignée s'acharnait une
bombe tout court et je déménage j'ai
acheté bombe récemment donc les formes y
est arrivé de landelles c'est fini c'est
la fin c'est la fin je suis triste non
oh [ __ ] c'était qu'à bord c'est du
mensonge rêve ça c'est totalement du
mensonge c'est la google pour arriver
moi je vous dis non mais là je suis tu
je suis plus en cap en capacité de faire
cette vidéo correctement tr qu'avant il
ya des gens qui ont du courage c'est
bien moi j'aime bien je suis content
pour eux des gens qui en ont beaucoup
moins
alors comment passer ça je pense pas
qu'on puisse sauter là bas on va le
tenter bonjour je saute au monde huit
alors il se passe comme on dit c'est le
capitain c'est le captif rende compte ma
peau on dira d'insectes par la somme
correcte bien par là non et bien sûr on
tient un petit filet ne le regardais un
petit à petit à petit flynn dans le vide
pas ouverture au bout je suis très très
bien
je suis moins bien je suis moins bien je
fais trop de style
alors qu'alou tâche il
fuck gravity ouais ouais ben jabr au wat
attendait sérieux et alors du coup à un
cube
bonjour c'est toi qu'il faut que la
gravité d'accord ok c'est mon tapis
volant regarder aux soirées dans le
géographe l'aide à la fois que je dors
et on y est on y est on y est
voilà monsieur monde du saas est déjà
compliquée a marre on regarde tout ça
une flèche la balle petit flash ni
calloway merci à flèches argentées marc
est la perspective est tous dans ce feu
sar au foot à la tête elle tournait tout
à prêter ma liénard est niet à grèzes et
voilà votre vidéo telle catastrophe
aujourd'hui rien ne pas nommer faisait
des fois il ya des jours comme ça vous
avez très bien on se lève et rien ne
vaut un bon run hésita pas aimé la vidéo
ça vous a plu aux atteintes aux biens
attendant une prochaine verser quand
même d'avoir regardé le boycott nous
amuser voilà c'était pas amusé et bains
les bains et ben tu prends cette clé usb
jamais sur ton pc comme ça claque tu
cliques sur j'ai kiffé point exe et
ensuite eu la vidéo de la photo sia a
bientôt les voir on va garder
j'ai pété un câble allez à bientôt